اعلن الرئيس الفرنسي امانويل ماكرون ان
بلاده ستعيد سفيرها من نيامي خلال ساعات
وانها ستسحب قواتها من النيجر بحلول
النهايه العام وقد رحب المجلس العسكري
الحاكم في النيجر بهذا القرار كان هذا خبر
حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما
حيثيات قرار ماكرون سحب قوات بلاده من
النيجر ما مدى تاثير الانسحاب الفرنسي على
المشهد السياسي والميداني بالنيجر كيف
سينعكس سحاب باريس من النيجر على مستوى
وحجم النفوذ الفرنسي في
افريقيا لان فرنسا وصلت الى طريق مسدود
وخاصه الرئيس ماكرون من الصعب جدا الابقاء
على هذه المعركه فرنسا رات وصلت الى قناعه
مفادها بان قوات الايكواس ليست جاهزه هناك
تردد كبير وان في النهايه التداعيات العمل
العسكري سواء كان من قبل اكواس بدعم فرنسي
او من جهه اخرى ستكون لديه نتائج وخيمه
على النيجر وعلى المنطقه اقد ان فرنسا
وجدت من موقفها الذي كان فعلا موقف دغ
ماتي كان موقف حادا كثيرا لم يترك اي فرصه
للتفاوض منذ البدايه في النهايه اصبحت
فرنسا معزوله الرئيس الفرنسي كان مجبر
امام الراي العام الذي جزء منه و كذلك جزء
من الاحزاب السياسيه كانت منذ البدايه ضد
القرار الفرنسي ضد هذا التعنت الفرنسي
اعتقد ان فرنسا وقعت تحت صدمه انقلاب
النيجر هي لم تتوقع حدوث هذا الانقلاب
اصلا وعندما وقع الانقلاب ارتبكت ووقعت
تحت الصدمه ان الموقف الامريكي ظل في خط
موازي للموقف الفرنسي خط اخر مختلف تماما
عن الخط الفرنسي وكان امريكا تريد وراثه
النفوذ الغربي في المنطقه على حساب فرنسا
فرنسا لديها مصالح ثقافيه واقتصاديه ريفا
تستثمر في يورانيوم الان الشركات الفرنسيه
حتى شركه الطيران الخطوط الجويه الفرنسيه
وهنالك مصالح اقتصاديه اذا استمرت فرنسا
في هذا التصعيد مع السلطات العسكريه في
نيامي يمكن ان تخسر كل
شيء وان اعتقد انه فرنسا ستدخل في مفاوضات
بطريقه مباشره وغير مباشره مع مع السلطات
الجديده في النيجر اما بالنسبه للرئيس
بازو فانا اعتقد انه انه عودته حتى في حال
يعني تدخل عسكري كان من الصعب جدا اعاده
ما تسميه الدول الاكواس بالمسار الدستوري
فرنسا ستفا وض من اجل سلامه الرئيس محمد
بازون وهذا هو اكبر شيء ممكن ان تحققه
بالاضافه الى الحفاظ على مصالحها
الاقتصاديه والثقافيه في في النيجر هذا
التراجع يعتبر تراجع يشكل انعطاف في
السياسه الافريقيه لفرنسا لان فرنسا كانت
تعول كثيرا على النيجر موقف اكواس سيتغير
مع التغير الموقف الفرنسي لانه من الصعب
جدا على اكواس القيام بعمليه عسكريه بدون
تغطيه جويه بدون اسناد من قبل القوات
الفرنسيه وانه لابد ان تتغير الحرب ضد
الارهاب لانه كل ما قامت به فرنسا مدعومه
سواء من قوات اوروبيه او حتى من قوات
امميه لم تؤدي الى نتيجه ايجابيه لا يمكن
استبدال الوجود العسكري الفرنسي التقليدي
بوجود عسكري لفاجنر او لقوات روسيه مباشره
هذا لا يحل الاشكال الاشكال يتعلق بضعف
الدوله في هذه البلدان الان اعلن عن تعاون
بين الدول الثلاث ماال وبوركينا فاسو
والنيجر وتم الاعلان عن هذا الاتفاق في ظل
وجود نائب وزير الدفاع الروسي هذه اشاره
الى ان روسيا ستقوم بسد الفراغ الفرنسي
ولكن هل هذا سيكفي لمواجهه
الارهاب ما جرى في النيجر وفي هذه الدول
هو خساره حقيقيه للوجود العسكري والسياسي
والاقتصادي والاستراتيجي لفرنسا ايضا
خساره هذه البلدان على النحو الحالي هي
خساره ما تبقى من نفوذ فرنسي في منطقه
الساحل ومع هذا لازالت هنالك دول تمثل
نقاط ارتكاز لفرنسا مثل السنغال وساحل
العاش وحتى الجابون وبينين وتوجو العسكر
ثاني النقطه ثانيه العسكر هم براغماتي
يعني بالطبيعه واعتقد انه مصلحتهم فتح
كذلك يعني تعاون جديد مع فرنسا يعلمون
جيدا بان فرنسا لها دور مهم جدا معتبر في
اوروبا والمقاربه مقاربه التنميه الشامله
تحتاج الى تمويل هذا التمويل لا يمكن ان
ياتي لا من روسيا ولا من الصين اعتقد ان
فرنسا ستراجع سياساتها لمنطقه الساحل
وينبغي ان تركز على موضوع الديمقراطيه
والمجتمع المدني بشكل صادق وايضا تراجع
موقف الاملاء على الدول الافريقيه وان
تستمع وان تقرا جيدا ما يجري في هذه
الساحه وان تكون محاربتها للارهاب محاربه
موضوعيه y